[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
this wasn't a bad decision
this wasn't a drug deal gone wrong
this was three independent decisions he
made
to him will the so-called daytona beach
serial killer be given the death penalty
and just days before a deadline to be
deposed former president donald trump
pushes back with a legal appeal plus
will the accused michigan high school
shooter be transferred to a children's
facility certainly should compel your
honor to be very concerned about placing
this defendant in a relatively less
secure setting which mirrors in so many
ways
the scene of his original crime but
first defendant brett hankerson takes
the stand in the death of brianna taylor
case i knew they were trying to get to
him
and it appeared to me that
they were being executed with this rifle
lawn crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everybody to long crime daily
i'm jesse weber in for brian buckmeyer
who's in kentucky following in the death
of brianna taylor case with me here in
new york as always is co-host terry
austin the defense rests its case after
defendant and ex-louisville police
officer brett hankerson takes the stand
for hours detailing the moments that led
up to the deadly shooting of briana
taylor hankerson is not charged in
taylor's death but instead stands trial
on charges of wanton endangerment for
firing shots into taylor's apartment
that went through the wall into the
neighboring unit hankerson was one of
three officers involved in a no knock
drug raid performed on taylor's
apartment in march of 2020 believing the
officers were intruders taylor's
boyfriend kenneth walker fired at them
the officers shot back and taylor was
killed in that crossfire former officer
john mattingly was also shot officials
say ex-officer miles cosgrave fired the
deadly shots that killed taylor on
wednesday henkerson took the stand in
his own defense and he told jurors what
led up to the shooting and later the
conversation that he had with kenneth
walker
i knew sergeant excuse me i knew
sergeant mattingly was down and i knew
i knew they were trying to get to
him and it appeared to me that
they were being executed with this rifle
so what did you do
i returned fire
through
excuse me through the sliding glass door
he wanted what was going on i said you
shot the police
and he said i did not shoot the police
and i said well who did and he said my
girlfriend
and i said
he said she shot you with her nine
and i said well where is she at because
i had no idea there was there was
another person inside at all and he said
she's dead inside
and what did you do then
back that kind of shook me because
you know there's only supposed to be one
person in that apartment and now there
was a
allegedly a girl dead inside
and that wasn't
that wasn't why we were there
our own brian buckmeyer was in the
courtroom for hankinson's testimony and
he joins us now live at the jefferson
county courthouse in louisville kentucky
brian it's good to see you we heard
henkerson's direct examination the
question is
how did he do on cross
yeah he did fairly well i would say
jesse now the prosecution and their
cross-examination push brett hankinson
in terms of what he could and couldn't
see the night that that warrant was
executed now hankson described how he
interpreted an active threat he said he
could tell there were different guns
being used in the shootout based on the
sound alone but we know from reports
that walker only shot once hankson also
said that he was absolutely sure he
wasn't firing at his fellow officers
when he shot through the window even
though he couldn't see them at times it
seemed like hank is in may have been a
little nervous wiping his bra brow and
fanning his jacket for air but to be
fair it is warm in the court prosecutor
waylon tried to but didn't seem to get
it out that hankinson can see the other
apartment doors on the first floor
suggesting he could have known about the
other potential victims in firing into
briana taylor's apartment finally
prosecution ended with and there is no
policy in the lmpd for giving
suppression fire however the prosecution
didn't really follow up on that point in
cross-examination but we expect her to
go deeper into that on closing arguments
thursday morning all right let's talk
about this a little bit so i'm joined of
course by co-host terry austin but also
legal analyst kirk nermey kirk it's good
to see you i want to start with you we
saw a testimony of hankerson breaking
down on the stand you know what i'm
going to ask you you think it was real
or manufactured
you know jesse i think we see the
witness stand over and over again as a
really emotional place we see a lot of
emotional breakdowns and keep in mind
jesse this testimony brought mr
hankinson back to emotional time
whatever we think of what he did
he witnessed his friend his partner
someone he cared about deeply rushed to
the hospital to check on after the
incident was over get shot and concerned
that that he might be actually killed by
this gunman to who he didn't know at the
time was behind this door so ultimately
jesse i think that the tears have every
reasonably those tears were genuine they
were authentic and they came from that
emotional place that we often see people
get to on the witness stand and just to
play devil's advocate they did come at
opportune times in his testimony and i
want to bring you now to terry the
cross-examination what did you think did
he make whether did the the prosecution
make any key points there
well i think the commonwealth did a
terrible job honestly barbara whaley
spent so much time on questions that
really weren't that relevant and she
didn't make any points for instance she
kept trying to say that he was trained
and so okay yes he was but then she had
him read letters of accommodation which
frankly only made him look better as far
as i'm concerned then she was trying to
say that he was backing out and
basically that he left his partners to
be killed well i think he established
very well that he was backing out
because he wanted to make sure that he
moved so he could address that threat
and frankly overall his demeanor i think
he was cool calm and collected and i
thought his tears were real frankly and
last thing i'll say about barbara is it
was rude at times and there wasn't any
need to be rude and i think that's going
to hurt her case at the end of the day
well brian i'll let you round it out you
were watching it were there any points
that stood out to you on direct cross
and maybe how did the jury react to
certain points during his testimony
so the jury is definitely a mixed bag
you can tell that many people are paying
attention some people kind of often
looking to the side but everyone was
awake this time it wasn't like the
cosgrove deposition but i think in terms
of this case both in direct and
cross-examination it looked like both
sides maybe brought up good points but
didn't really hammer them home in a way
that i think would have been more
powerful for the jury and it really
looks at this point i think it could go
either way i think this case is going to
be ultimately decided uh with the
summation looking at some of the
charging conferences though it looks
like it may lean a little bit more to
the prosecution in terms of what
defenses will be brought to the to the
jury but i think at this point the
defense may have a strong case
like i say with so many other cases we
will wait and see brian buckmeyer
excellent reporting as always thank you
so much still ahead on long crime daily
will the 15 year old accused oxford high
school shooter be moved to a children's
facility but first former president
donald trump files an appeal to block
judge order depositions that's ahead on
long prime daily
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle
watch lawn crime every day with youtube
tv we put you in the jury bonus
[Music]
and welcome back everybody former
president donald trump pushes back at a
new york judge's ruling by filing an
appeal to avoid court-ordered
depositions this appeal comes just days
before a march 10 deadline for trump and
his children ivanka trump and donald
trump jr to provide statements under
oath this comes as new york attorney
general leticia james spearheads a civil
investigation into the financial
dealings of the trump organization james
is investigating whether trump misled
investors or insurers with business
financial statements trump's attorneys
argue that a.g james should bring the
family before a state grand jury
investigating the trump organization if
she wants to hear their testimony and
all this comes just one week after the
resignation of two new york city
prosecutors who were leading a separate
manhattan district attorney's office
investigation into trump's business
practices so clearly a lot to talk about
kirk i jump back to you um what do you
think letitia james is trying to find
out by deposing deposing the trump
family what do you think that's going to
add to her investigation
well you know jesse i think a probable
defense to charges like this with
financial documents what have you is
that you know i
the the defense would be the relying on
the professionalism of the attorneys the
accountants everyone that was involved
in the preparation of these documents i
think what ms james might be looking for
is kind of the intent and knowledge
how involved was the trump family former
president trump his daughter how
involved were they in their preparation
these statements what statements went
over how involved were they did they
were there any fraudulent things done on
their behalf to mislead their
accountants what have you so i think
that's kind of the line of exploration
she's going down to cut off any possible
defenses and of course see if they
contradict anything that she already
knows to be true so as kirk said there's
a lot to gain from james but a lot to
lose for the trump family right terry
and i'm curious attempts to avoid this
the strategy they've been invoking right
now is it effective is it working
i actually think it is effective look
he's done it before he did it when he
was being impeached those proceedings
were delayed he either denied he
deflected and at the end of the day
those types of tactics seem to work for
him and it's working right now he waited
until the last minute to appeal the
decision which really basically gives
him more time he has every right to do
that he's arguing that these depositions
shouldn't proceed because of the you
know criminal suit but listen i think
the longer he takes to delay these the
better it is for him and one of the
things the judge said is look you can
sit for these depositions but you can
always take the fifth and in fact that's
what eric trump did when he was deposed
yeah i agree so if he ends up sitting or
his children end up sitting that's maybe
what the testimony might end up being
but at the very least they're trying to
avoid it for now coming up on long crime
daily the penalty phase continues for
the convicted daytona beach serial
killer plus the deadly oxford high
school shooting where a michigan judge
rules accused shooter ethan crumbly will
be held until trial
[Music]
and welcome back everybody legislation
which would make lynching a federal hate
crime passes by a landslide vote in the
u.s house with only three votes against
it it's called the emmett till
anti-lynching act named after the
infamous 14 year old black teenager who
in 1955 was kidnapped tortured and shot
in the head after allegedly whistling at
a white woman at a mississippi store the
woman's husband and brother-in-law were
tried and acquitted for his murder by an
all-white jury the two later confessed
to actually killing him and that woman
carolyn bryant more than 50 years later
confessed to lying about till hitting on
her in the very first place under the
law a crime could be prosecuted as a
lynching if someone is killed or hurt
during a hate crime lawmakers have
failed to pass anti-lynching bills more
than 200 times in the last 120 years
lawmakers are encouraging the senate to
take up the legislation if passed there
and then it will head to the president's
desk
searching now to michigan where a judge
denies the request to move the accused
oxford high school shooter to a juvenile
facility after a compelling argument by
the prosecution
the sampling of text messages you've
been provided between defendant and his
friend date back to february of 2021 and
they reveal much about the defendant and
certainly should compel your honor to be
very concerned about placing this
defendant in a relatively less secure
setting with juveniles and certainly one
which mirrors in so many ways the scene
of his original crime
on tuesday judge kwame roe ruled crumbly
will remain in the oakland county jail
for adults saying quote it is clear that
children's villages is incapable of
safely housing the defendant citing
eight escapes from the children's
village in the last month judge rowe
also referenced items of grave concern
in crumbly's journal saying crumbly
quote noted he killed eight infant baby
birds by slowly torturing them until
death crumbly faces multiple charges
including terrorism causing death first
degree murder and assault with intent to
murder for the oxford high school
shooting in november of last year
officials say crumbly opened fire at the
school killing four students and
injuring eight others prosecutors say
his parents jennifer and james crumbly
ignored warning signs leading up to the
shooting and they now face four counts
of involuntary manslaughter a review
hearing on ethan crumbley's placement is
slated for march 24th so kirk you know
crumbly's defense attorneys are saying
that he's being held in quote extreme
isolation at the adult county jail
they're saying it's causing more harm
than good to their clients mental health
is that an argument that's eventually
going to hold up
i don't think so now jesse there's no
doubt about the fact that mr crumbly has
severe mental health problems that are
probably exacerbated by the solitary
confinement
but really
there are no alternatives right i mean
when we talk about
moving him to a juvenile facility that's
had eight
escapes and is is the prosecutor said in
irreally
accurate fashion that it would be like
the setting of his crime that is just
simply unacceptable and would be tone
deaf to those same problems that led to
this crime likewise obviously he could
not be in a general population so given
all that i don't think that argument is
ever going to hold water and that he is
where he's going to be now and if that
results in mental health consequences
they will have to medicate and work
their way out of that from that point in
time but right now i don't see this
confinement ever changing before trial
but terry should there be alternatives i
mean do you think there should be
additional holding options other than a
children's village or the adult county
jail for someone like in his position
absolutely no doubt about it jesse i
think that neither facility is ideal if
in fact the children's village isn't
secure enough and we know it isn't
because as kurt just mentioned there are
all of these individuals who have
escaped then the adult facility is not
ideal because he should not have to be
in isolation and there is the chance
that his mental illness is only going to
be exacerbated if he is in that
condition and so i think there should be
some other place where children in
particular who have mental illness can
be housed and they can be protected and
they can be assisted so right now we
don't have that but it's something we
absolutely need
sad case all around
when we come back will a convicted
killer be sentenced to death or receive
life in prison attorneys make their
final pleas to jurors in the penalty
phase of the florida case of serial
killer robert hayes when we return
welcome back to long crime daily we head
south now to florida as the prosecution
and defense present their closing
arguments as part of the penalty phase
in the case of convicted serial killer
robert hayes
last week a jury found hayes guilty of
three counts of first-degree murder for
killing laquita gunther julie green and
awana patton in daytona beach in late
2005 and early 2006. this was a cold
case which nearly took 15 years to solve
hayes was convicted with their murders
after a fourth woman rachel bay was
killed in west palm beach in 2016. hayes
dna was linked to the three deaths and
he was arrested in 2019. now he faces a
separate trial in bay's death for the
penalty phase of the first three murders
several people have given testimony
before the jury who will ultimately
decide if hayes should be sentenced to
life in prison or the death penalty on
wednesday prosecutors told jurors that
hayes killing not one but three people
shows his true character
if you kill someone before
then that is a lot of weight
think about that if somebody is willing
to kill miss gunther
acquire a gun and shoot her and leave
her in an alley
and walk away
and come back two to three weeks later
and that same individual
kills someone else
he shoots miss green in the head so
after he kills miss gunther
miss green
then six weeks later after he's already
killed two people ended two human lives
what does he do
he makes a conscious choice
he makes a decision
and he decides he's gonna end somebody
else's life he's gonna kill another
person this wasn't a bad decision
this wasn't a drug deal gone wrong
this was three independent decisions he
made
to him
well hayes defense attorney made a plea
to the jury asking them to sentence him
to life in prison instead of the death
penalty
prison
without parole
is forever
you're not going to hear any jury
instruction that says they're going to
get out or depart or anything like that
if you sentence
mr hayes to life in prison
forever
you will be sparing his life
but you're also assuring that he will be
locked up and spend
his last moment in prison all life is
important all life is valuable including
the the three lives that were were taken
in these homicides
all i can say is all lives matter and
the point now for you to decide is
whether
mr hayes gets executed
or goes to prison without parole forever
all right kirk what do you think you
think the prosecution sufficiently
demonstrated aggravating factors that
outweigh any kind of mitigating
circumstances here you think the death
penalty is going to be imposed
yeah jesse you know ultimately when my
experience with the death penalty has
taught me that when you have multiple
victims
and you have a lengthy criminal history
as mr hayes has you have more than
enough in order for the death penalty to
come forward and we've heard some
mitigation but given those aggravating
factors i've talked about along with the
cold calculated nature of this the
serial killer s nature of this i think
it's more than enough for the state to
get the conviction they want get the
sentence they want and i think
ultimately sometime soon we will see mr
hayes being sentenced to death well
terry you know there was evidence about
his mental health there was evidence a
little bit about his upbringing let me
ask you this if the jury recommends
death couldn't the judge be persuaded to
overrule the jury's decision and impose
life in prison i think we've seen that
happen before could that happen here
it could happen here it's a distinct
possibility you know there are only 27
states with the death penalty obviously
florida is one of them but if the jury
recommends death dutch really actually
could say
look i think that the mitigating factors
outweigh the aggravating factors here
the judge is supposed to give great
weight to what the jury is recommending
but he could say that these 45
mitigating circumstances that the
defense said
really were circumstances that could
outweigh those two aggravating factors
the prior murders and the calculated
cold premeditated nature of this case so
i think the death penalty will probably
stand but the judge does have the right
to say that these mitigating factors
overruled and frankly these mitigating
factors there were so many of them i
really didn't think that they were
enough but the judge could say
particularly that mental illness is
something that would make him say no
there should be no death that this
should be life without parole and even
though you have a death qualified jury
this decision is always unpredictable so
like i said we'll wait and see kirk
terry thank you so much everyone out
there thanks for joining us here on long
crime daily we're gonna see you next
time as we discuss justice in america
we'll see
[Music]
[Music]
you